hi in this video we would quickly
describe the concept of affinity and
avidity
of antigen-antibody interaction so these
two terms determines the interaction
between antigen and antibody not only
interaction the strength of interaction
and the degree which and also the
kinetics of the interaction between
antigen and antibody so antigen and
antibody interacts in multiple non
covalent way and all these interactions
are reversible so most prevalent
interactions are hydrogen bond ionic
interactions then hydrophobic
interactions and Vander Waals
interactions all these are relatively
weak interactions and they are
reversible so affinity is a measure of
the strength of interaction between the
epitope that means the specific
antigenic determinants and the
antibodies and antigens binding site so
between these two the binding strength
is known as affinity now affinity could
be defined or could be described in the
simple thermodynamic principle which
governs the biomolecule biomolecular
reversible interactions so assuming
there is antigen and antibody is making
a complex and these complex these
complex could be broken down as well and
that is why this interaction is
reversible and this is denoted by simple
equation like mentioned here so the
equilibrium equilibrium association
constant would be simply defined like
this and the dissociation on the other
hand would be determined like this and a
ratio of association vs dissociation
would give the binding affinity of an
antigen antibody reaction now this
antigen and antigen-antibody interaction
is happening at a molecular level so we
were talking about a microscopic level
which would and the measure of this
microscopic interaction is affinity now
let us talk about at a macroscopic level
that means antigen antibody could have
multiple different antigen binding sites
I mean that is determined by its valency
for example IgA has four antigen binding
site where I GM has ten so the overall
interaction between all of these antigen
potential antigen binding site is
collectively known as avidity so we can
simply understand avidity as affinity at
a macroscopic level now every DT is
dependent upon three major parameters
definitely affinity of the antigen
antibody towards its epitope so greater
the affinity greater would be affinity
as well then valency of the antibody so
greater the valency greater would be IV
DT for example IgM has greater affinity
than ijt and last but not the least is
the molecular arrangement of the epitope
and the antigen antibody antigen binding
site inside the antibody so this
three-dimensional arrangement sometimes
can allow conformational change that
would help in further stronger
interaction sometimes so all these 3
parameters are important to describe the
ability of antigen-antibody reaction so
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked this video give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you